bonjour à tous
il est l'heure de parlement hebdo une
émission politique et parlementaire que
j'ai le plaisir d'animer avec mickaël
zeze bonjour bijoux 10h45 pour
décortiquer toutes l'actualité politique
et parlementaire et à la une cette
semaine la loi elle conneries sur la
réforme du travail toujours très
contestée entre 170 mille six cent mille
personnes ont manifesté dans toute la
france jeudi en marge des cortèges de
violents affrontements ont eu lieu entre
casseurs et forces de l'ordre à paris
rennes marseille ou nantes forte
amélioration sur le front économique la
croissance repart autre bonne nouvelle
cette semaine la baisse du chômage
soixante mille demandeurs d'emploi au
mois en mars notre action porte ses
fruits déclare le ministre des finances
ça va mieux a déclaré françois hollande
à la télévision ils ont donc voulu
martelé ce message une vingtaine de
ministres s'est réuni lundi à paris
c'est et au la gauche une initiative
lancée par stéphane le foll pour
défendre le bilan du chef de l'état
alors ça va mieux on nous demandera
d'autres invités qui commentera toute
l'actualité de cette semaine du
carbonate bonjourbonjour sénateur maire
d'alfortville où vous allez commenter
donc toute cette actualité et on va donc
commencer par ceux qui a marqué ce début
de semaine c'est ce cri du coeur et au
la gauche
et vous le savez on n'est jamais mieux
servi que par soi même et donc les
arrivées fidèles de françois hollande
étaient réunis lors d'un meeting à paris
objectif défendre le bilan du
quinquennat moissac jean baptiste
daoulas et au la gauche c'est
l'expression pas très courante choisi
par stéphane le foll pour défendre la
politique de françois hollande
c'était une interpellation le système à
dire mais on est critiqué tout le temps
critiqué mais et où regarder quand même
ce qu'on a fait et comme l'adage veut
que l'on n'est jamais aussi bien servi
que par soi même
ce sont une vingtaine d'actuels et
anciens ministres de françois hollande
qui se charge de défendre le bilan du
président avec des éléments de langage
soigneusement préparés sur le plan
économique les choses vont mieux
la france va mieux mieux qu'elle ne le
pensait le même un élément de langage
pour rassurer les français et un autre
pour mettre en garde ceux qui comme
emmanuel macron veulent dépasser le
clivage gauche droite parce que la
réalité c'est que la gauche et la droite
c'est pas pareil la droite et la gauche
n'est pas la même chose emmanuel macron
est absent mais les principaux ministres
sont là pour énumérer les mesures prises
depuis 2012 retraite à 60 ans prime
d'activité mariage pour tous le meeting
prend alors des airs de thérapie de
groupe pour faire croire à 2017
seule femme ministre de gauche je veux
aussi vous dire que moi je n'ai pas
renoncer à la victoire en 2017
j'appelle faut que l'on apprenne les
frondeurs à ne pas se tromper de caen il
y a personne à gauche qui doit vouloir
faire contre la cause le meeting a
galvanisé les partisans de françois
hollande
mais il n'a pas rassemblé au delà de la
majorité les frondeurs
europe ecologie les verts et le parti
communiste ont critiqué l'opération le
quart vous signez vous même ce vendredi
dans le monde une tribune avec 23
parlementaire
en somme c'est un soutien à françois
hollande ça y est c'est parti en année
un soutien à françois hollande j'espère
que nous sommes tous dans la majorité
présidentielle
oui oui bien sûr il ya toujours les
collègues que l'on qualifie de front
depuis le début de ce quinquennat
tout est bon cette opération est au la
gauche si elle peut être utile met une
pièce de plus dans la machine de la
compréhension vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens tant mieux je pense
sincèrement que c'est pas le rôle des
ministres de faire ça mais est-ce que ça
sert ce genre d'initiative c'est plus
une méthode coué non ça peut toujours
servir pendant un moment où on en parle
de ce qu'on a faim
donc tout ce qui peut servir à rappeler
le bilan c'est utile mais est ce que
c'est le rôle des ministres de le faire
je crois pas pourquoi c'est parce que
c'est le job du parti socialiste et je
crois que les français qui nous
observent qui attendent justement que
les résultats soient de plus en plus
positif
il attend des milices qui soit au
travail et non pas dans la peau qu'ils
auraient tort de se réunir comme ça à
part girafe à ces médecines je pense que
vous l'avez dit michael ça mais ce sont
les amis historiques de france hollande
mais là aussi j'ai cru comprendre que
nous étions tous
hollande est donc c'est le mouvement
répondre à gauche de 2011 qu'ils
proposeraient familiales voilà de
stéphane le foll qui prend aujourd'hui
l'essor de veiller aux la gauche donc on
comprend que c'est la préparation de la
candidature j'imagine de de françois
hollande à l'élection présidentielle
vous critiquez le fait que ce soit les
ministres aujourd'hui oui parce que
c'est dangereux
eux les ministres il faut qu'ils soient
à leurs tâches sont à 100% ce qu'ils
doivent faire le job de l'explication
dans le texte et les parlementaires
j'en fais partie vous l'avez dit j'ai
signé une tribune et c'est le parti
socialiste donc les violences ne sont
pas à l'ordre du jour ne faut faire
aussi attention à l'image que ça renvoie
parce que quand on est dans ce genre
d'initiative faut pas se tromper
et si ça renvoie l'image d'un d'entre
eux soit avec des élus et des
collaborateurs d'élus c'est le cas un
peu beaucoup quand même oui je pourrais
dire les choses donc je suis pas sûr
tout ça participe au delà de ce qu'on
imagine que ce serait donc c'est bien
oui mais c'est une expérience qui peut
être utile mais encore une fois je veux
que cette énergie soit plus consacré
dans le parti socialiste dont je suis
secrétaire national ou tôt
jean-christophe cambadélis autour de la
belle alliance populaire
pourquoi je dis ça parce que je vois
maintenant que patrick kanner veut faire
un héros la gauche à lille que les amis
de martine aubry 10 en plus ça va se
faire sans nous donc merci du rhdp
plusieurs initiatives qui ont été
lancées à briser la belle allure surtout
à plusieurs initiatives dans les régions
n'y en a qu'une c'est celle initiée par
jean christophe cambadélis celle de la
belle alliance populaire
moi je les fritures sur la ligue
autrement je dise non non je ne souhaite
pas non c'est très bien que ça a été
fait encore une fois est d'ailleurs moi
je participe à cela dans la tribune
il est ici ici par ma collègue et ami
frédérique espagnac s'appellera bon ça
est utile on en a parlé ce a permis de
rappeler le bilan jusque très bien le
petit reportage à témoigner mais encore
une fois
moi je suis maire d'alfortville en mai
habitants ils disent tous les jours
bon bah c'est très bien c'est très bien
mais
on veut que les ministres soient
justement à leur charge il ya comme
macron lorsqu'il nous a juste avant par
les maquereaux un grand absent de et où
la gauche était manuel valls qui n'était
pas là il n'est pas comptable du bilan
du gouvernement
il est chef du gouvernement c'est lui
qui est au bilan
écoutez il y avait dans son calendrier
dans son agenda parlementaire pardon je
suis pas son chef de cabinet proche de
manuel valls mais je veux bien être
comptable de tout mais pas de son agenda
quand même en tous les cas
l'initiative a été initiée par stéphane
le foll il y avait beaucoup de ministres
et ça donne quoi elles valent sens mal
je constate que j'aurais eu le drian n'y
était pas que bernard cazeneuve n'y
était pas que manuel valls n'était pas
comme neil mac ronnie était bassiste
manuellement par les manuels mac on va
en parler puisque c'est un ministre qui
fait particulièrement parler de lui en
ce moment
il multiplie les déplacements les
petites phrases qui me motive c'est de
façonner l'avenir de mon pays at il dit
à un journal allemand
alors emmanuel macron qui promet une
nouvelle offre pour 2017 leur carte luc
carvounas elle qui sait ce qu'il doit
clarifier sa position
c'est lui le dire moi je constate que on
marche a débuté à amiens et qu'il est
déjà en marge à paris visiblement donc
faut faire extrêmement attention je
pense que emmanuel macron est un
vrai produit l'ascenseur républicain
c'est une cette année c'est un esprit
brillant cette caisse qui veut faire il
veut être j'imagine candidats à
l'élection présidentielle y croyez ou je
le pense il faut qu'il soit clair il
n'organise pas un mouvement comme celui
là sans avoir l'idée peut-être d'être
candidat après j'ai entendu qu'il était
loyal à françois vous savez je vous dois
rester ministre ou pas mais c'est pas à
moi de le dire moi de le dire mais elle
va mixer la créature de françois
hollande incarne qu'elle a dû arriver
on saura dans quelques semaines très
rapidement s'il est candidat ou pas
parce que j'imagine que si c'est son
architecture est ce qu'ils prévoient
tiens il quittera le gouvernement mais
en même temps je trouverais ça dommage
qu'il quitte le gouvernement parce que
c'est quelqu'un de brillant et que vous
voyez ce qui manque c'est cette notion
du collectif mais pourquoi ça manque
ben parce qu'on va trop vite dans une
carrière politique au congrès quelques
étapes
l'étape du rapport à la fidélité l'étape
à la construction politique à la famille
qui vous a permis et donc d'être là où
vous êtes
il va à mon sens dans ce qui est mon adn
à moi trop vite parce que moi j'ai
appris ce que c'était a étant un enfant
issu d'une famille prolétaires
l'ascenseur républicain je les prie
aussi mais j'ai appris aussi ce
qu'étaient les codes en politique
notamment le rapport à la fidélité et je
trouve ça très étrange que celui qui
vous a construit en l'occurrence
françois hollande a construit emmanuel
macron certains même accusé que c'était
le fait du prince qui l'avait nommé
ministre
aujourd'hui de le voir pousser des ailes
verra notre avenir faut juste faire
attention qu'il ne vienne pas icare on
passe à mardi mardi le chômage était à
la une
forte baisse du chômage en mars 2016
mois 1,7 pour cent soit soixante mille
demandeurs d'emploi en moins du jamais
vu depuis 16 ans de bons résultats
saluée par la ministre du travail
ecoutez-la moins 60 milles ce la
meilleure baisse mensuelle depuis 2000
voilà donc depuis 16 ans et j'ai
l'habitude vous le savez pour ceux qui
me suivent dans chacun de ces annonces
des chiffres mensuels du chômage
j'ai toujours l'habitude de rappeler et
tous les services statistiques ne disent
également qu'il faut regarder les choses
en tendance sur les trois derniers mois
la tendance allait très clair c'est
moins cinquante mille demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie à
sur les trois derniers mois donc non la
baisse n'est pas timide
la baisse est importante et c'est une
bonne nouvelle
le carbonate on entend des mirabelles
comme réel parle de tendance on voit là
ça a baissé au mois de mars à remonter
au mois de février
on peut pas vraiment parler d'une baisse
continue de la courbe du chômage oui
mais on doit quand même réaliste moi je
fais partie de ceux qui depuis le début
de ce quinquennat mais morrow dans les
pires difficultés je dis toujours vous
allez voir les réformes structurelles
posée par françois hollande et manuel
valls vont porter leurs fruits je l' ai
toujours dit il croyait toujours à
l'inversion d'ici la fin de la vidéo sur
billy tendance les plantes
macroéconomique c'est pas vrai qu'il dit
ce sont tous les experts elles sont là
elles le prouvent
mais en même temps je me souviens d'un
échange de vues avec un sourire depuis
lyon qu'ils aillent à un nom déjà dit
même si ça valait mieux prendre cette
pression les français parce que ça va
arriver tard auront du mal à le voir
voir ne verront pas du tout doux tout la
nécessité de cette pédagogie a martelé
et ça c'est le job du parlement table
que je suis et surtout pas une valve de
président et comment nous présidons il
est le chef de l'état le chef des armées
il doit être à l'initiative de
l'organisation de la politique
gouvernementale ce qui fait très bien
voilà je pense que
le président de la république a été
peut-être mal conseiller en
communication c'est pas à lui de dire ça
va mieux lui il est dans l'action ce
qu'ils doivent dire ça va mieux ce sont
les français et ce sont les français
parce que nous les parlementaires encore
une fois plutôt que de regarder notre
nombril ou de tirer un peu la couverture
sur nous-mêmes comme le font certains
dans la majorité présidentielle
nous sommes sur le terrain moi je disais
je suis bien d'alfortville jeu sur le
terrain en permanence je confronté à la
aurait elle en permanence et donc ça
c'est de travailler nous et nous notre
travail c'est d'être derrière le
président de la république est de faire
en sorte qu'ils soient demain j'espère
réélu le chômage baisse la croissance
repart on les a tout à l'heure tout est
réuni pour que françois hollande puis se
représenter en 2017
moi j'ai toujours dit écoutez sous la
vème république le président sortant
et le candidat légitime après nous avons
ou s'il a conditionné sa candidature
quand même à la belle a conditionné ah
oui oui je vous dire depuis maintenant
quelques heures quelques jours on a
moins soixante mille chômeurs de moins
et j'entendais ce matin sur une chaîne
concurrente thomas piketty qui vient
nous dire hop hop hop hop hop c'est 60
milles c'est très bien mais on a quand
même 658 chômeurs de plus sur le
quinquennat
alors il faut faire quoi finalement
toujours dire que ça va pas donc oui on
le dit ça va mieux oui oui ça va mieux
oui les français ne voient pas que ça va
mieux et oui il faut utiliser tous les
relais locaux que nous sommes nous les
maires les premiers guichets
républicains pour expliquer pourquoi ça
va mieux et moi je le vois dans mon
bureau quand les petites tpe viennent me
voir me dise monsieur le maire le carré
comment il repart donc il faut qu'on
soit dans 7 dans cette énergie là et moi
je suis persuadé que la courbe du
chômage
meriem comrie qu'une miss très
courageuse qui dit que la courbe est une
tendance
eh ben on va faire en sorte avec
françois hollande et manuel valls
emmanuel macron que la tendance
s'accélère alors autres temps forts de
l'actualité parlementaire c'est la
réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature voté conforme par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat et qui
pourrait ouvrir la voie à la tenue d'un
congrès le ministre de la justice y
tient mais la majorité des trois
cinquièmes des parlementaires semble
quasiment impossible à trouver
jean baptiste daoulas l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le texte
un vote de l'assemblée conforme à celui
du sénat
françois hollande est désormais libre de
convoquer un congrès sur la réforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
libre sauf que l'opposition des députés
les républicains l'empêchent d'atteindre
la barre des trois cinquièmes nécessaire
pour valider la réforme
le congrès semble donc compromis même si
le ministre de la justice espère encore
convaincre quelques députés de droite
il ya aussi des parlementaires
on dit je pense à georges fenech par
exemple secrétaire justice du des
républicains qui m'a l'occasion beaucoup
dit pendant les débats en commission son
attachement à l'indépendance de la
magistrature pour moi je fais appel à la
conviction
je demande que les postures soit oublié
mais les députés les républicains ne
semblent pas prêts à faire de cadeaux
ils dénoncent une réforme a minima qui
ne changerait rien depuis 2008 le
gouvernement suit déjà les avis du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour les nominations au parquet moi
j'appelle de mes voeux une plus forte
une réelle indépendance de la justice
encore une fois c'est ça va au delà
d'une simple mesure technique qui nous
est proposé et qui est très en retrait
du projet initial qui avait voulu
président de la république
donc tout cela me paraît aller dans la
précipitation ne touche pas la
constitution
on ne touche je dirais la caution que
d'une main tremblante et lin
manifestement on n'est pas danger dans
un contexte qui permet de le faire c'est
donc désormais un bras de fer qui va
s'engager entre la majorité et
l'opposition
quitte à prendre l'opinion publique à
témoin je crois qu'ils montrent que si
on fait le calcul quarantaine de voir il
appartient au président devant un public
de juger s'il peut prendre le risque
d'aller à versailles en n'étant pas
certaine de gagner ou si le fait de
perdre par exemple nous permettrait de
mettre la droite devant ses
responsabilités sur la question de
l'indépendance des parcs et le président
du sénat gérard larcher a déjà indiqué
hier qu'il était hostile à une
convocation du congrès le carbonate vous
croyez possible la tenue d'un congrès
sur la réforme du csm tous les cas elle
céderait formelle a été votée dans les
deux chambres parlement après pour le
congrès s'était bien dit il faut les 3
5e
moi je vais vous dire
moi je souhaite qu'on y aille au congrès
faut tenter le coup faut qu'on y aille
au congrès parce que franchement de
comptable d'indépendance de la justice
du fait que le csm donne son avis sur la
nomination des magistrats et là on est
en train de nous dire la droite qui est
une année de l'élection présidentielle
qui nous fait la ritournelle c'est pas
assez il faut regarder danse à sucy de
réformes jean-jacques sur quoi la région
larcher le garde des sceaux a eu raison
mon ami urvoy sa raison il faut aller au
congrès il faut que le président de la
république comme il l'avait dit aux
françaises et aux français réunissent le
congrès chacun prendra une bonne fois
pour toutes ses responsabilités et pas
nous faire la petite leçon comme au
moment de la déchéance de nationalité
chacun prendra ses responsabilités vous
n'avez peut-être pas de majorité de
chacun un chèque du congrès peu importe
on verra mais à cause de qui sera
l'échec - selon vous m'interrogez c'est
mon souhait voilà je ne souhaite pas
comme j'aurais aimé si vous m'aviez
interrogé il ya quelques années connaît
même au congrès sur le vote des
étrangers aux élections passées ont plié
chacun doit prendre ses responsabilités
c'est ça aussi le parlement s'est pas
plus de 900 parlementaires aux réfugiés
des à la décision d'un seul homme que le
chef de l'état en congrès en conscience
et en conscience politique
chacun devra s'exprimer alors on va
passer au mercredi sur un tout autre
sujet les sénateurs s'intéresser aux
lanceurs dallaire et vous savez en ce
moment il ya de nombreux pots cei et de
procès notamment de luxe l'x c'est le
cedar pendant ce temps là qui se penche
sur le statut de ce qu'on appelle ses
lanceurs d'alert comment mieux les
protéger tout en défendant le secret des
affaires cette drôle de problème et les
explications sont signés bouillir
sociaux nous revient dans un instant ses
lanceurs d alerte font un travail utile
pour la communauté internationale ils
prennent des risques
il doit donc être protégé cette
intention énoncés dès la révélation de
la sphère des panamas papers devrait se
traduire dans la loi le texte sur la
république numérique examiné par le
sénat possède un amendement créant un
statut pour les lanceurs d'alerté
informatique
il serait protégé des poursuites
judiciaires en cas de divulgation de
failles d'un réseau aux autorités
concernées
depuis 2007 six lois tente de définir ce
statut aujourd'hui seules les personnes
révélant des informations sur des
dangers sanitaires
r ou environnementaux bénéficient d'une
protection solide la loi anti corruption
des entreprises porté par michel sapin
contient des dispositions en faveur des
lanceurs d'alert le ministre des
finances souhaite les protéger contre
les représailles en leur accordant un
dédommagement financier et en prenant en
charge leurs éventuels frais de justice
le vote de la directive européenne sur
le secret des affaires pourrait
contrarier ce projet elle donne des
moyens juridiques supplémentaires aux
entreprises pour poursuivre tous les
acteurs journalistes ou citoyens
révélant des informations
confidentielles
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ses danseurs
d'alain michel sapin par exemple qui
veut rémunérer fait leur valeur pour
qu'ils aient un vrai statut final mais
il a raison je crois même qu'il a
annoncé que dans la loi sapin de et
regarderai à renforcer justement le
statut des lanceurs d'alert faut faire
extrêmement attention là encore quand on
entend directive européenne surtout
cette défiance sur une forme d qui
chapote finalement nos vies quotidiennes
en france quitterait repris par les
populistes et marine le pen la première
et jean luc mélenchon en 2d moi je dis
attention après panama peppers qui a
montré une grande liste à la prévert où
il ya des politiques des sportifs des
gens du monde de l'entreprise dame en
quoi une caste une élite qui au dessus
de toutes les lois qui finalement les
s'entendent plus tous pourris c'est même
là la mondialisation est passée par là
moi je souhaite que la france et le
président de la république a eu raison
de la firme et de le marteler joue sur
ce sujet là cette question est tout à
notre honneur à la france à la
république
le fait de devoir laisser comme seul
message où il est le sort d'alert
doivent être protégés oui on doit
renforcer toutes celles et tous ceux qui
finalement font quoi améliorent la vie
démocratique de nos pays et de la france
en particulier
on passe à l'actualité française c'est
un géant français qui voit rouge la
dette d'edf ne cesse de gonfler
l'entreprise doit-elle continuer
d'investir auditionné par les sénateurs
le pdg d'edf jean bernard lévy s'est
montré serein
jordan qu'un allonger la durée de vie
des centrales existantes 51 milliards
d'euros
le p r dean clippers en grande bretagne
16 milliards de projets ambitieux que le
président d'edf a confirmé ce matin
devant les sénateurs
mais les finances du groupe pose la
question de leur faisabilité
la dette s'élève à 37 milliards d'euros
et pour l'instant rien ne laisse
présager un avenir plus radieux pour
l'entreprise
mais le pdg d'edf se montre ferme quand
il s'agit dink les 'points je voudrais
vous dire que le report d'hinckley poynt
ne me semble pas opportun
certains évoquent la possibilité de
reporter le projet après la mise en
service de flamanville et de taishan
et ce n'est à mes yeux ni nécessaire ni
faisable
et pourtant le père de flamanville
piétine et l'action d'edf a chuté de
moitié alors faudra-t-il augmenter les
prix de l'électricité un scénario
inenvisageable imaginez le gouvernement
augmente les prix les prix et à dire les
tarifs réglementés
que va faire le consommateur le client
il va quitter ses tarifs réglementés
pour aller sur le marché
à la question des finances s'ajoute
celle de la sûreté récemment ségolène
royal a indiqué vouloir étendre le
périmètre de sécurité autour des
centrales de 10 à 20 km cette zone vise
à protéger la population les biens et
l'environnement en cas d'incident
nucléaire
on voit bien dans quel état est
l'entreprise edf vous autant que mr par
exemple si on d'augmenter les tarifs
d'edf quelle serait votre réaction
à votre avis je ne sais pas votre avis -
qui fait en sorte depuis que je suis
maire de ne pas augmenter les impôts
locaux et je ne le fais pas malgré les
contraintes de dépenses en moins
demandés par l'état pour l'effort
collectif
évidemment non mais vous voyez la
réserve apple fallait au secours d'une
grande entreprise française il faut être
d'une grande aide nos grands fleurons
donc il faut que l'état il était monté
au créneau plus de premiers l'état est
actionnaire majoritaire
donc il faut renflouer le capital de ce
que je comprends il faut aussi regarder
que edf à 37 milliards aujourd'hui des
dettes et un investissement sur un plan
à 2035 qui s'élève à 100 milliards sans
oublier le renflouement aussi d'areva
qui sera à venir
c'est plusieurs milliards je crois que
certains l'estiment à 10 ou 11 milliards
de da d'argent qui affola retrouver pour
que tout ça soit dans une équation
équilibré et que ça ne viennent pas
pénaliser l'usagé donc moi je fais
confiance pour le coup au pdg d'edf
confiance aussi à l'état actionnaire
il faut laisser en cette matière là
celles et ceux qui sont à la commande de
faut pas venir parasiter ce chemin qui
est en train d'être trouvée
edf doit investir en angleterre doit
construire les réacteurs d'une capote
comme c'était prévu une 23 milliards
d'euros ce contrat
oui en même temps il faut qu'on ferme
fessenheim
et à fleurier les dommages edf on y est
donc jeu pour rappel l'accord en 2012
avec les verts bien sûr et est
responsable aussi les relations avec les
je suis apolitique je le suis à nouveau
voilà un métier un sms depuis le 9 avril
dernier secrétaire national aux
relations extérieures
donc oui je me rappelle de tout cela
mais il va passer là non je parle de
l'équation il ya un médiateur qui a été
nommé pour voir la compensation à devoir
obtenir pour edf
encore une fois c'est un de nos fleurons
il faut pas qu'on s'engage sur du tout
et son contraire et c'est pour ça qu'on
a nommé monsieur olivier à la tête
autre sujet vous allez présenter une
proposition de loi de votre votre groupe
ce sera le 10 mai prochain une
proposition de loi pour lutter contre le
tabac oui il s'agit en fait d'imposer
des quotas au pays sur la consommation
des particuliers puisque vous nous
expliquer la philosophie de votre
proposition déjà pour ses grandes pour
celles et ceux qui nous regardent eux il
existe une directive mondiale par
l'office mondiale de la santé qui date
du 30 novembre 2015 et qui a été repris
par les deux chambres là aussi au
parlement qui qui dit quoi ces
directives
en gros que pour lutter contre
finalement une forme de commerce
parallèle des cigarettes dont le monde
organisée par les cigarettes raf et que
même si 1000 milliards six mille
milliards de cigarettes produites à
l'année sur les 6000 milliards chiffres
de l oms 12% sont re router par le site
chrétien main sur du commerce parallèle
de manière encore plus exacerbée quand
on est en zone frontalière puisque les
prix les taxes ne sont pas les mêmes
vous voyez ce qui est en train de se
mettre en oeuvre sur du trafic et donc
alors demandé comme ça permettrait de
réguler rasseoir les quotas déjà demandé
au gouvernement de prendre le décret de
la directive de l'homme qui nature est
toujours parfait il a toujours pas été
pris et qui vont quoi aussi ce décret
demandé ça la technostructure qui qui ce
décret dit aussi que la traçabilité du
paquet neutre cigarettiers peut pas être
juge et partie est faite par un
organisme indépendant et moi ce que je
souhaite c'est dans ce projet loi
renforcer cette directive en imposant
des quotas et on revient à la question
vous me posiez qui permettrait de
fournir dans chaque pays la commune
européenne le stocks équivalent à la
consommation domestique et non pas un
stock inférieurs parce que là aussi
c'est organiser ce qui permet sur les
réseaux transfrontaliers de faire ce
commerce parallèle que je vous évoquez
les cons quand on donne moins
donc il faut consommer ce conte ce dont
on a besoin et les cigares étaient
organisées ce cela de données mois par
rapport à la consommation domestique que
l'on sait mesurer avec l'om et
concrètement comment on les fixe ses
quotas est ce que c'est à l'état de le
faire concrètement les fixes je pense
avec l' oms avec l'europe mon collègue
par mon collègue l'epargne oki député
européen qui est très alerte sur le
sujet est un bon relais de la question
tout cela doit se faire en bonne
intelligence
encore une fois ça n'a d'intérêt que
pour ramener trois milliards aussi
d'euros dans les caisses de l'état parce
que ce commerce parallèle 3 milliards
d'euros est un trou de 3 milliards et ça
renvoie 250 millions d'euros de perdus
chaque année pour nos 26 bis le
buraliste et j simplement que les
buralistes en france ils sont à 42 %
dans des communes de moins de 3500
habitants et au moment où il crée des
maisons eux mêmes des services publics
dans leurs locaux ils deviennent le
premier voire le seul relais de
proximité
ben moi je me résous pas à les voir
mettre la clé sous le paillasson et à
laisser les bras ballants ce commerce
s'organisant par alain bolduc arruda si
cette proposition de loi n'est pas
accepté par vos troupes qu'est-ce qui se
passe en tout cas je moi je suis
légitimiste suivi serai dans mon groupe
socialiste je veux en parler avec le
groupe convaincre mon groupe pour cette
ppl soit déposée après qu'est ce qui se
passe j'espère que le débat fera que
j'aurais emporter le morceau d'accord
donc on en reparlera voilà aux alentours
du 10 mai c'est bien derrière la tâche
est grande date de dimanche opposant
jeudi les opposants à la loi elle comme
riz manifester
nouvelle journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme du travail des manifestations
ont eu lieu dans toutes les villes de
france en marge des cortèges de violents
affrontements ont éclaté alors à paris
notamment marseille ou nantes 124
personnes ont été interpellées dans tout
le pays 24 policiers et gendarmes ont
été blessés dont un très grièvement à
paris alors luc carvounas les
organisateurs se sont laissés déborder
comme le sous-entend le ministre de
l'intérieur d'albi l'auteur
malheureusement raison bah oui sont
laissés déborder suffit de regarder ce
qui se passe chaque soir quand il lève
le camp comme on dit d'autres préparent
un autre camp et j'entendais ce matin
même sur une onde radio qu'ils
s'organisent les policiers étaient
effarés de voir ce que sous les tentes
il changer de vêtements ceux qui
justement même des exactions pour se
faufiler dans la population qui sont des
citoyennes et citoyens qui ont envie de
se retrouver pour y discuter j'ai cru
comprendre c'est mais j'y suis allé un
très objectivement et je n'ai donc pas
les manifestations mais c'est un cetain
touya de lui debout il ya les
manifestations etc aubry fait la même
chose ni de bord et les casas et des
activistes gauchiste mais bien sûr pour
ceux qui cassent à la fin de l'année
deux bouts et ceux qui se retrouvent
dans les dents les manifestations de la
loisne conneries on voit bien que nos
jeunes s'en servant comme a dit nicolas
sarkozy
non j'ai peut-être pas jusque là parce
que nicolas sarkozy est un habitué de
l'outrance verbale et du mépris du
citoyen général non mais que ce soit sur
les lois là les manifestants dont la loi
travail et les débordements gauchistes
autour ou ce que je vous dis sur ce qui
se passe tous les soirs à nuit debout
ce sont à peu près les mêmes et les
mêmes corpus est ce que les syndicats
doivent condamner les violences comme
bien sûr qu'ils le doivent enfin
j'espère que tout républicain condamne
les violences
encore une fois manifesté c'est un droit
et en france on a même parlé de l'état
d'urgence et en france on a même le
droit de manifester pendant un état
d'urgence
donc c'est formidable voyez la
démocratie qui nous sauve qu'à partir
d'un pablo sa devancière l'état
d'urgence
lyon s'est pas seulement un danger pour
la plupart aux manifestations l'état
d'urgence a été mis en place pour
renforcer pour de police et de justice
par rapport au terrorisme pas que la
légende urbaine d'empêcher des
manifestations dans tous les cas
aujourd'hui
il faut condamner très fermement très
durement toutes celles et tous ceux qui
que ce soit dans le cadre de
protestation qu'on doit entendre dans la
loi travail ou que ce soit dans le cadre
de mouvements citoyens intéressant qu'il
faut regarder j'y suis allé pour nuit
debout on peut pas autoriser que cela
vienne tout dévoyé il faut interdire
mais debout non pas au rendez-vous mais
ni de route devra quand même c'est du
coup moi j'ai l'impression ça j'y suis
allé une fois les rencontrer au tout
début
ah ben si cette jeunesse pas forcément
tout âge jeunesse qui est un peu le
miroir de notre jeunesse plus
réactionnaires qui s'étaient rassemblés
pour la manif pour tous donc moi
j'entends ce j'entends nos jeunes qui
s'interrogent sur leur avenir je le
méprise pas moi même ma première manif
temps 86 j'avais 15 ans et contre
devaquet donc faut pas mépriser ces
mouvements citoyens mais faut pas non
plus en faire l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
action politique présente et à venir
vous parler de la ville travaille
d'abord peut-être est-ce que vous
imaginez que le gouvernement puisse
sortir l'arbre vous savez cette fameuse
arme de 49 3 c'est visiblement ça a
quand même très compliqué mais vos corps
de la faire passer à l'assemblée
nationale je serais assez étrange
puisque entre le moment où il s'éteint
discrétion dans le journal le monde la
décision du premier ministre
d'interrompre pendant quinze jours pour
pouvoir de discuter avec l'ami du
travail et le texte qui est encore en
discussion je vois le rapporteur sirugue
damman sur des questions comme le cd
détaxés pas taxées mais je vois le
bureau national qui est quasi
unanimement et compris les collègues qui
sont pourtant généralement la voix des
frondeurs te considérer qu'il a vu de
belles avancées de fait après je
voudrais qu'on m'explique pourquoi des
députés de gauche n'irait pas voter un
texte qui sanctuarisent ça va le cdi
oui mais général jusqu'à présent nos
textes passent mais sur un texte aussi
symbolique
je ne souhaite pas moi je suis sénateur
le texte arrivera au sénat plus tard que
le 49-3 soit employé à l'assemblée
nationale vous êtes sénateur et il s'est
passé quelque chose cette semaine c'est
que le sénat a décidé de saisir la
justice
sanogo l'homme qui est soupçonné d'avoir
menti sous serment devant une commission
denquête c'était une commission d
enquête parlementaire sur la pollution
de l'air il aurait caché ses liens avec
l'industrie pétrolière
quant à kamel vous explique tout cela on
ne revient d'en discuter dans un instant
c'est une décision inédite est prise ce
matin à l'unanimité des membres du
bureau du sénat
ce dernier estime que la déclaration
sous serment du professeur aubier devant
la commission denquête le 16 avril 2015
selon laquelle il n'avait aucun lien
d'intérêt avec les acteurs économiques
pouvaient apparaître mensongère
mensongère car le professeur aubier
auditionné sur la question de la
pollution de l'air en tant que
représentant de l'assistance publique
les hôpitaux de paris était au même
moment salariés par total mais devant
les sénateurs le médecin ne mentionne
pas cette information alors même que la
question lui est directement posée miss
le biais qui lors de cette audition
minimise l'impact du diesel sur la santé
publique expliquant que le nombre de
cancers dans les pathologies
respiratoires liées à la pollution de
l'air est extrêmement faible pour les
laïcs y avait taux d'is youn et le
professeur au billet la saisine du
parquet est une excellente nouvelle
je salue cette décision parce que le
mensonge et du professeur aux vielles
lors d'une commission denquête est un
grave et grave pourquoi parce que la
question qui nous concerne est qui
préoccupait c'était une question de
santé publique puisqu'il s'agissait
d'une commission d' enquête sur le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air et qu'il a menti à une
commission denquête d'un au sein de la
représentation nationale et que de fait
il a menti aux français le professeur
aubier encore jusqu'à 75000 euros
d'amendé et cinq ans d'emprisonnement
voilà un peu quand même c'est une
décision historique de la part du bureau
du sénat qui a décidé de saisir la
justice
oui je voyais que vous saluer la
décision version du sénat estimez-vous
que l'institution a été lésé dans cette
affaire ça c'est la justice qui le dira
apps on le sait le bureau du sénat d'ici
de saisir la justice paix implique à
vous le savez j'ai écrit un livre sur
les institutions je pense que
il faut que les institutions que les
commissions permanentes que lorsque l'on
aditionne sous serment que chacun
reprenne les règles rôle de ce que l'on
doit de ce qui se doit et donc cela
participe aussi à revenir en lien avec
nos concitoyens qui ne croient plus à la
politique a pas de moment où quelque
chose qui ne convient pas qui ne
fonctionne pas le bureau et qui eut un
mensonge visiblement le bureau a eu
raison de saisir
et qui mieux que vous parlez des
institutions vous avez peut-être vu ce
sondage cette semaine où les sénateurs
les députés font plus du tout la
confiance des citoyens
le maire reste encore vous le savez très
bien le reste plus mais reste en tête
que ce soit le parlementaire sénat et
assemblée
et puis de lire il ya plus de confiance
mais c'est presque normal j'ai envie de
vous dire entre l'assemblée nationale
nous avions de l'or entre les mains la
gauche nous dirigions ce pays nous
dirigeons encore et nous avons offert un
spectacle finalement de division tout
gauche confondues d'où la nécessité de
cette pédagogie qu'on évoquait au tout
début de l'émission il faut commencer à
faire l'inventaire
je suis ok nathan soit bien sûr c'est
très important de faire un vrai avant
terme et qui vaut aussi pour nos
partenaires qui nous ont abandonné en
rase campagne pas un inventaire entre
socialistes que le pc les écologistes
qui dirige comme alfortville la commune
avec moi le département ensemble du val
de marne où la région nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition ensemble
qui nous disent pourquoi malgré le
contrat gouvernement que nous avons mené
ensemble il ya quelques années ils ont
rompu ce contrat il suffira pas de me
dire c'est le cic eux c'est l'histoire
du discours
notre ennemi c'est la finance ça sera un
peu léger donc cette introspection
on a tous intérêt à la faire et c'est
pour moi la seule le seul socle qui
pourra nous relégitimer tous ensemble
parce que moi je souhaite que il fit
nous repartions tous ensemble pour
pouvoir justement éviter que ne vienne
demain une droite que j'appelle que j'ai
appelé avec claude bartelone par la
campagne ile-de-france cette droite
cette droite dure vous avez fait des
erreurs comme le constate manuel valls
dans le magazine society aujourd'hui
vous fait des horreurs
pendant ce quinquennat la gauche a fait
des erreurs en tous les cas je pense oui
on a présentement on fait des erreurs
pour avoir un tel niveau de défiance
alors que notre action
si elle avait été plus lisible n'aurait
pas dû aider q comme ça mais après vous
savez le peuple français c'est un peuple
pour selon moi très politique il suffit
pas à même d'avoir un très bon bilan
souvient de 2002 lionel jospin
donc c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes investies les maires et nous
sommes investies les parlementaires pour
faire juste en sorte qu'un truc que la
gauche puisse enfin assumer son rapport
au pouvoir et c'est ça aussi l'interview
de bonal valenciennes justement c'est
l'exercice du pouvoir de la gauche
manuel valls on en reparle avec notre
partenaire la loupe du scan gym jarrassé
nous a rejoint
bonjour j'ai déjà assez bon jour alors
justement vous avez ok cette interview
de manuel valls dans cette équipe qui
sort aujourd'hui
il liste les erreurs du quinquennat il
parle de de l'antisarkozysme que que la
gauche a mis en avant comme seul ressort
au début du quinquennat il dit on n'a
pas suffisamment assumé le virage
économique et sécuritaire
un droit d'inventaire fait par le
premier ministre à un an de la fin du
quinquennat est ce que c'est une bonne
méthode
oui il est dans son rôle si le chef de
la majorité
il a été mis là par le président de la
république pour à la fois animer cette
majorité puis mettre en place la
politique voulue par le président la
république celle pour laquelle il a été
élu le 6 mai 2012 où il est dans son
rôle et il est dans son discours de
vérité que je lui ai toujours reconnu
avoir c'est de dire les choses de les
nommer et on a vraiment un complexe nous
la gauche on me le disait avant de
gagner le 6 mai 2012
moi ça vous avez dix ans 80 donc j'ai
pas connu comme d'autres cette première
victoire
on me disait tu vas voir la gauche on a
un complexe dans le rapport au pouvoir
je voulais pas y croire parce que moi je
suis de la génération qui avait gagné
toutes les élections intermédiaires et
donc je les lis pas possible pas avoir
gagné toutes les villes les départements
les régions et avoir un compost de
rapport au pouvoir quand on va diriger
le pays et c'est malheureusement ce qui
s'est produit est ce que pour manuel
valls n'est pas finalement un moyen de
ceux de prendre un peu de distance avec
ce quinquennat pour ceux déjà se placer
dans l' après 2017
est ce que vous croyez que c'est le rôle
du
chef de la majorité de se placer dans la
presse moi j'ai toujours entendu et je
fais partie de ceux qui sait ce qui
revient sans cesse qui sombre se remet
finalement moi ce que je sais de lui
c'est que l'on parle des institutions
c'est qu'il a chevillé au corps
justement nos institutions et leur
fonctionnement c'est même à moi qui suis
un de ses proches il ne m'évoque jamais
les échanges qu'il a avec le président
de la république parce que ce ne sont
pas des échanges admin aime les échanges
entre le prix en art public et son
premier ministre
et donc si je dis cela c'est que quand
on parlait du rapport à la fidélité de
cette culture politique qui m'a été
éduqué quand on parlait d' emmanuel
macron vis-à-vis de françois hollande
manuel valls est un homme extrêmement
loyale est extrêmement fidèle à celui
qui lui a fait confiance en le nommant
au poste jusqu'au bout il a nommé lattes
et après mais écoutez moi j'ai été le
directeur de campagne de manuel valls
aux premières primaires citoyennes et
républicaines en 2011
et moi j'ai toujours vu en manuel valls
notre candidat pour être j'espère en
2022 président de la république mais
pour moi cet état j'ai toujours dit
passait par la réélection de françois
hollande si tenté qu'il soit qu'ils
soient candidats puisqu'il a su jti un
critère important sur la baisse du
chômage
dans tous les cas j'ai toujours été
clair 2022 donc ça reste l'objectif
mais pour ça il faut qu'on réussisse
2017 parce que si on perd 2017
la gauche va même plus explosé elle va
imploser on va avoir beaucoup parce que
nous le ps on impose peut-être le
regarder ce qui se passe chez les
écologistes chez les communistes où il a
pu de gauche et est ce que le risque
pour manuel valls n'est pas de suivre un
peu la trajectoire de françois fillon
qui a fini son passage à matignon très
allumées et qui encore aujourd'hui dans
la compétition pour la primaire
comptable du bilan du princess du
précédent quinquennat reste que c'est un
risque
c'est la première fois qu'on me compare
aussi ouvertement mais bon
vous pouvez aussi me le comparer à un
jacques chirac a été produit nice et qui
est devenu président de la république
voilà donc moi je sais pas quelles sont
ce type de comparaison tant que je vois
pas comment se déroule la fin de ce
quinquennat
d'ailleurs françois fillon même lui-même
candidat aux primaires à droite pour
être candidat est élu président en 2017
faut arrêter de se comparer les uns et
les autres parce que du coup à force de
se comparer les uns les autres
ça laisse entendre même à des gens
brillants qui a ni de gauche ni de
droite le fait est que le fait est que
manuel valls est dans une mauvaise passe
en termes de popularité en semant
regarder cette courbe cette enquête
harris qui vient de sortir on voit que
la cour de manuel valls continue de
baisser alors que celle de françois
hollande remonte légèrement ils sont
plus qu'à quatre points d'écart dans les
sondages
est ce que le premier ministre peut
finir le quinquennat moins populaire que
le président de la république
écoutez le premier ministre quand il a
accepté cette mission après une débâcle
municipal il l'a fait ce pari audacieux
que pour une la première fois peut-être
le tandem président la république
premier ministre pouvait être un tandem
qui se fasse marche pied l'un l'autre et
que ce soit un couple sans une feuille
de papier entre l'un est lourd ni
présent la république remonte dans les
sondages tant mieux prémices baisse un
peu dans les sondages pendant ce moment
là
je le déplore a je me batte avec
d'autres pour que les choses changent
dans tous les cas il n'y a pas de y'a
pas regarder encore une fois l'un est
avec l'hôte et l'un va avec l'autre et
ce qui peut faire pour se relancer on
sait que chaque été il a l'habitude de
prononcer un discours à ses personnels à
ces politiques à vauvert notamment
est-ce que vous l'appelez à faire la
même chose cette année un an de la
présidentielle à se dévoiler encore il
ya des choses que je comprends pas on
nous on nous dit que la croissance
premier trimestre et au delà des
espérances même si certains de + 0 1
on voit qu il ya moins soixante mille
chômeurs de moins on voit que la
croissance est là le pouvoir d achat des
ménages repart et malgré ça j'entends
qu'est ce que manuel valls doit faire
pour se relancer mais se relancer sur
quoi sur la politique il en train de me
dis qu'est en train de réussir cette qui
est l'exemple du tandem hollande valls
france françois hollande et son premier
ministre vous maintenant aller jusqu'au
bout de son quinquennat sur les réformes
pour lesquelles ils ont été mandatés
n'attendez pas de moi de vous sortir il
n'y aura pas de rôles à gauche
valls il y aura par ailleurs à ba2 en
marche
on n'a jamais fait de courant nous nous
notre famille car tu sais le parti
socialiste est ce qu'il doit continuer à
parler d'identité manuel valls on l'a
entendu parler du voile comme un signe
d'asservissement d'affirmer que le
salafisme étaient en train de gagner la
bataille dans les banlieues c'est des
termes assez fort qui ont été parfois un
peu critiqué par certains de vos
camarades social que sk millions en
banlieue monsieur non bon moi je vis en
banlieue j'y suis né je suis même devenu
le maire de la ville de banlieue je suis
né donc je comprends très bien ce qui
est en train de dire manuel valls sur le
salafiste dans les salles de prière qui
est en train de s'installer mais aussi
parce qu'il ya dans certaines villes de
banlieue une fois je le dis ici de
complaisance de ce que j'appelle le
premier guichet républicains que sont
les maires parce que ça les arrange de
banias électoraliste alliot marie
lemoine l'islamo gauchisme c'est un
terrain tout l'éclat reprenait je laisse
à jean marie le guen ses propos en tous
les cas je comprends très bien ce que
manuel valls décrit lui qui a été maire
d'une ville de banlieue que moi et qui a
vécu longtemps donc
encore une fois il faut manipuler les
termes avec beaucoup d'intelligence moi
vous savez sur le voile
là aussi je dis faisons attention aux
mots parce que l'islam pour moi les
généraux marine le pen dit quand tu
entends manuel valls parler d'islam j'ai
l'impression de me lire oui mais marine
defrennes je pense qu'elle ferait bien
de nous dire où il en est dans sa tête
parce qu'elle est dans un délire total
juste merci avant de quitter ici mais
vous aviez accusé le président du sénat
avec le site d'être partial dans des
questions d'actualité de privilégier un
peu la droite écoutez ce qu'il vous
réponde est totalement faux j'ai fait un
petit statistiques que j'ai rapporté il
ya trois semaines en conférence des
présidents
la différence entre socialistes et
républicains ces 52 centièmes de seconde
pendant trois mois vous rendez compte si
carvounas sensible c'est un sprinteur et
même les communistes ont dépassé de 8
secondes
16 les écologistes de 7 secondes pour
vous rendez compte par monsieur
carvounas il faut qu'il reprenne son
cours de m vous avez eu votre camp de m
j'ai pris mon chrono m et puis vous
savez dans la gestuelle quand on a les
bras fermé c'est que on est fermé à la
question c'est la psychologie de la
gestuelle et puis moi je plains le
collaborateur de cabinet du grand des
comptes mandaté par gérard larcher quand
j'en ai parlé qui a dû regarder trois
mois précédents polonais au centième
près donc son chrono guette ces luttes
il invente mais si on a des problèmes de
comptage pour des photos au moment des
jo on va demander à son collaborateur de
cabinet donné le mettant en détachement
à paris et bordeaux fera passer le
message merci beaucoup du carré d'as
merci d'avoir été ainsi avec un
diversité parlement hebdo c'est terminé
pour aujourd'hui merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis très bonne journée à tous
sur les chaînes parlementaires